[Applause]
foreign
activist who ran onto the field with a
pink smoke bomb at Levi's Stadium in
Santa Clara California on Monday night
during a game between the Los Angeles
Rams and San Francisco 49ers has filed a
police report for assault by Rams
players who tackled him to end his
demonstration where we should probably
watch that moment purely for educational
purposes because there's the guy he's
not nude at least usually these
streakers are and then oh he gets he
gets taken out see that is well let's go
back and look that again yeah that's a
form form tackle there's no helmet to
helmet there um he's leaning so he's
leaning he's he's leading with his
shoulder and it's really it's a shoulder
against shoulder tackle that is well
within the rules of the NFL if you step
out of the football field well now you
are it's what matters are are the rules
of football yeah in a normal
circumstance if you're just taking a jog
down the street and someone runs up and
tackles you then that's assault but on a
football field in between the sidelines
the rules are different probably the
ultimate example of uh F around and find
out as the kids would say